écoutez nous sortons nos conseils
stratégiques la position est claire nous
sommes dans l'opposition
dans l'opposition au gouvernement et à
emmanuel macron nous avons combattu
prononcer ces élections législatives et
nous resterons bien évidemment sur cette
ligne dont il n'est pas question ni de
pacte ni des coalitions des quelques
accords de quelque nature que ce soit en
revanche
nous produirons comme nous l'avons
toujours faire une opposition
responsable c'est à dire en étant force
de proposition sur chacun des textes qui
seront proposés et nous présenterons
soit avant la fin de l'été soit soit à
l'automne une série propositions sur les
différents sujets qui sont les sujets de
préoccupation des français au quotidien
que ce soit sur le pouvoir d'achat sur
la sur la sécurité sur la sur la santé
sur sur l'immigration sur l'éducation
nationale est ce que vous direz que jean
françois copé est d'isoler
la débat ça tout à l'heure et la
position que je vous donne la casse est
unanime
ultra majoritaire si jean françois copé
conseil social inades autre jour et
aussi des points de rapprochement en
revanche il n'est pas question ni
d'impact avec le gouvernement dit d'une
coalition de quelque nature que ce soit
nous sommes en opposition à la fois à en
marche pour rassemblement national et à
l'extrême gauche et nous restons sur
spider est ce que c'est que ces
propositions
oui et c'est des propositions de loi que
nous ferons en accord avec le groupe du
sénat et nous allons préparer ça
rapidement mais déjà dès maintenant sur
tous les sujets d'actualité et celui qui
a eu le plus pressant et occupe
aujourd'hui c'est celui du pouvoir
d'achat donc nous avons un certain
nombre de compositions on a pu débattre
d'ailleurs pendant la campagne et que
vous revenez mais c'est un cocktail qui
ne soit pas celui partout des 69 des
goûts des élus elle est rouge
craint rien dans ce dans ce domaine et
nous aurons lierre je pars dont nous
aurons demain un bureau politique ou
on sera à nouveau ses 69 députés sont
eux-mêmes fête ses soixante deux députés
est à ce stade peut-être qu'il va y en
avoir d'autres une information je la
prend avec plaisir avec les tv écoutez
ça c'est la position est claire nous
sommes est-ce que j'ai l'air et 62s que
vous redoutez que le à terme le groupe
puisse d'être saturé en deux n'ont
aucune aucune crainte de cette nature
nous avons fait campagne ensemble et
nous restons jeter sans aucune
difficulté il est difficile de faire
non parce que je crois que la position
que j'avais exprimé hier soir avaient
été reçus très favorablement l'immense
majorité à la poigne aux parlementaires
et nos dirigeants sur le pouvoir d'achat
vous nous parlez propositions à l'été
mais le texte de la maison des vagues
médiatrice et sera nous
écouter le sas avec le travail de nos
deux groupes parlementaires nous allons
mettre en avant 4 5 4 ou 5 points mur et
je suis très bien c'est au gouvernent la
balle 11 aces et c'est au gouvernement
de dire de prendre en considération ce
qui s'est passé au moment de moment du
vote jamais un gouvernement en est aussi
faible jamais un président de la
république était aussi fragilisé avec
toute la difficulté qui était la sienne
de définir une ligne politique
d'ailleurs on l'a vu hier au discours de
la première ministre
ça c'est le rôle du président de la
république c'est à lui de vous savez le
premier ministre
nommé par les nazis il est responsable
devant le parlement c'est sa décision
non je ne sais pas non non non je sers
tu manques savez on a l'habitude des 10
sport le schéma qu'on ait de la réalité
qui est bien souvent très éloignés donc
j'ai aucune idée de ce qu'il y aura de
la
qualité par exemple rue d'égée pas je
peux comprendre que ce n'était pas à
l'ordre du jour a tout de suite mais
c'est un sujet sur lequel nous avons
nous des propositions très claires sans
doute
tendu
le geste il avait 5 ans pour le faire en
agissant de manière responsable il a
fracturé le pays comme jamais il a
instrumentalisé les extrêmes et
aujourd'hui il a mis effectivement la
france dans la situation que l'on
connaît
nous nous sommes pas contre moi force de
proposition c'est à dire dans une
opposition résolue les responsables
c'est sa décision c'est sa
responsabilité
il est président de la république il a
nommé ce qui aurait été logique c'est la
première ministre après le résultat des
élections dépossédé mission dont la
parfaite mais c'est la responsabilité du
fraser mais je ne suis pas président de
la république ses prières la république
qui nomme le premier ministre
la nuit baisse de jean luc mélenchon
notre des premières les premiers signes
de fragilité prévision de division cet
après midi comment vous analyser cette
situation écoutez la nuque mais c'est un
artifice de communication
bon c'est bien parce qu'on connaît
toutes les différences de sensibilité
qu'il y a qu il ya à l'intérieur ce qui
est des contacts entre la majorité et
les
absolument aucun
la team de débauchage présent
tout et je pense que en matière de
débauchage ce qui devait être fait a été
fait
plus tôt
j'ai pas beaucoup d'inquiétude vous avez
été député qui sont élus aujourd'hui
parce que personne n'est sur cette île
oui pense que l électro nabeul mais non
seulement elle est noble mais je pense
que la cour ait conforté on le reverra
prochaines échéances électorales mais
nous sommes encore une fois sur une
ligne qui est la nôtre c'était très
difficile après avoir fait moins de 5%
présidentielle de remonter aujourd'hui
on a treize très ennemi très et demi
pour cent c'est une remontée très
importante il était difficile d'aller au
delà bien évidemment
bah écoutez jeunes ont déjà de voir si
le président de la république va va
demander un vote de confiance au
président de la république qui n'est pas
capable d'avoir une majorité au
lendemain de son élection est ce qu'à ce
sujet on peut imaginer que vous
accordiez alors les attendait non même
chose qui est très clair si le présent
la république devant le vote de
confiance de retrouve bien évidemment
pas la confiance je suis pas sûr que la
demande
aucun député l'air ne votera la
confiance du gouvernement mais je pense
que la confiance sera pas demandée mais
après tout c'est à 8 prendre ce risque
il peut y avoir des situations douce et
sur la même position que les rênes et la
nièce
non mais on sera sur nos positions après
si d'autres les rejoignent on verra mais
nous nous serons sur notre ligne d'en
face se positionner par rapport à tel ou
tel on ne l'a jamais fait pendant cette
campagne des législatives on a conservé
notre indépendance et une solidité qui
nous a peut-être coûté cher mais au
moins on peut se regarder dans une glace
nous le ferons en lien étroit et nous
l'avons évoqué avec un collectionneur
qui qui étaient là d'avoir des liens les
plus étroits possibles pour préparer et
effectivement les textes ensemble
mais bon merci à vous
[Musique]